hi welcome to a new video han code
tekken tutorials I'm your host Matt
ekeus as promised I would do another
visual studio video part two if you will
on how to compile libraries maybe this
one should have been first before how to
include them at all but oh well oh well
when you when you make a project and you
want to add stuff to it
I'm sorry C's plus plus project it can
get a little tricky so what we're
looking at here is GL fw now g o fw is a
basically a little system for setting up
display windows that way you can render
stuff inside window inside window a lot
of people use it for OpenGL and other
various purposes so when you go to their
page J lfw org and you go to download
the latest you get it in a zip file and
when you open that up I've got a lot of
stuff in here I've already got it once
before as you can see there and I'm
getting it again which is fine we'll go
ahead and isolate that over here we'll
just do a fresh one so you take the zip
file and you want to basically extract
it however you want I'm just gonna do an
extract here so put it around my desktop
I'm using P zip you can use whatever you
want
you know there's WinZip WinRAR learn all
those once you extract it and open the
folder you'll see something like this
you think okay there's includes where's
my libraries well it's not quite how it
works you need to do a little more you
basically need to compile it for your
version of Windows and add it to your
development stuff you will see AC make
folder here this concludes pretty much
everything you need but you do need to
go get C make- C mokou org and download
C make I've already done this so I'm
just gonna launch C make you'll get a C
make GUI and you can see I've done spree
vyas work but
I want to start this over so I'm gonna
browse the source and I'm gonna go to my
desktop and to that gfw folder and to
think this all I need yeah just the root
here is fine of whatever you're doing
and you can do browse build this is
where you want it to build to and
obviously I want to build it somewhere
else I'll just build it right within
this folder and we're gonna make a new
folder and just call it built I think
this is what most people do and I'll
just select that build folder so there
we go that's how you get it set up and
get ready let me get rid of this my page
I think you guys probably seen enough of
that
very good very good all right so what
from here you might ask first you hit
configure it's gonna prompt you for some
stuff we want Visual Studio 15 2017
that's right and you can specify
anything you want we're gonna use
default native compilers no additional
arguments and let it do its configure
it'll show you its information as it
goes down here and then once that's all
done you generate and I'll say
generating done and then you do we close
my visual studio here then you do open
project which should automatically open
it in Visual Studio so this is
relatively straightforward you don't
have to do like any coding or much
special stuff you kind of just run it
through this process and we're gonna do
an all build here so you select this all
build and you basically want to change
this to release win32 since I'm doing
all 32-bit stuff in this case then you
just hit the play button let it do its
thing and it'll run it through the
compiler like this Claire
from the window it's really bright
outside you run it through the compiler
and let it do its thing and I'll show
you the next step here shortly
[Music]
it says unable to start program that's
okay we don't actually want to start
this program we just want to build it so
maybe it would have been better for me
to go to build and build solution but in
play but it's fine too there's not
actually anything to run with jl fw it's
something that you code up with your
your project so it says down here at the
bottom build 28 succeeded zero failed
zero eight zero skip that's good we got
all successes so we can get out of here
we basically want to go to this build
folder that we specified and see make
and you want to add it to your
development folder in Visual Studio now
I've got a a root folder I use it's
actually called OpenGL maybe it should
be called development or something
because that's kind of what it is and in
here I have includes and libraries no in
my includes you know this is GL fw and
i've got a dot h you know dot native so
that's one thing to bring in and you
need to library the glf w dot live so
that is one thing you have to bring over
you drag that over into your library
folder and you want to drag over your GL
fw folder nowhere is that there's the
include folder it's right on right on
the root the bill gives you basically
the library that you need that's that's
what you need from there the include is
probably already there just from
downloading it's just these two headers
and those go in here
both of which already have the same size
let me just double check that my
libraries are the same size see if I
happen to have got the new one what was
that was a build so I'm gonna go back
folders libraries there it is now these
are vastly different sizes okay I've got
a much smaller library here so that's
kind of tripped me up DFW 3 don't live
let's just let's just search within this
whole project for DL fw 3 dot live and
see you okay there's only the one and
it's 216 kilobytes
as opposed to my previous one which was
573 so that's a little strange
all right so when you're in Visual
Studio as I said in last the last video
the part one of this little series here
about using Visual Studio as your main
IDE you basically want to point your
includes and libraries to these if
you're doing it for your your whole
development section with a global
globally you would use your little
development folder often called
development I'm calling my Open GL I
really should probably just call it
development let's just see that right
now that's what most people tend to do
so you would point your includes and
you're in your libraries there and then
link them and that's pretty much pretty
much it now if you wanted locally on
your project of course you got to copy
those over all this stuff over locally
into your project as I kind of said in
the last video I'm not gonna go over
that again but that is how you compile
them
when I build it before the studio here
I'm guessing when I build it before I
build it some other way maybe I think I
might have built rel with dad nympho
which was released with debug info I'm
pretty sure that's why I have a bigger
library currently because with the debug
info it's going to be much bigger so if
you want the debug info you can compile
it that way if not you just do plain
release you can do min size release
that'll give you a smaller library file
so it's up to you how you want to you
want to do those know a lot of these
libraries are like that when you
download them and unzip them you'll
notice they have a C make and if you
look at their general instructions it'll
basically say open them in C make and
configure whatever we did you know it
configured and generate and then open
and then build it so that's basically it
and I think that covers this video if
you guys have any questions please let
me know and if you have anything to add
anything I may have missed let me know
one other thing I should note was gonna
open a project here last video I was
working on this little engine thing and
just kind of showing an example of how
to get to the properties under project
properties and then you can also right
click here and get to the properties you
know for doing all your configuring if
you're confused about how to configure
these recommend watching my previous
video but I should also note that I as
you can see I have my real folders shown
here I don't think I talked about this
in the last video you got to click this
show all files to show your actual file
structure which is so weird if you're
used to editing through folder
structures because visual studio by
default doesn't show you folder
structures it shows you sorts sorry
about my camera and all this weird light
but it's not about my face anyway so I
guess we're good like it does a sort of
all your headers sort of your resources
a sort of your source
these aren't actual folders these are
like a sort folders if you want to see
your actual folders you got to click
this show all files and then it shows
you your actual file structure which is
nice because you can organize things how
you actually like them and there's my
lives and my includes of course its
project to set up locally and if you
have any dot dll's that your project
relies on to run you do have to put them
on the root of your project and and once
again yet another way to get into
properties you can click this little
properties gear here so I don't know
there's probably like five six different
ways to get to the same properties I
don't understand why programs do this
just make one simple way to get to
properties like clicks quick side rant
like this when you first open this it
looks huge there's so many different
things to do but what you might not know
is that lots of these are duplicates
lots of these are just the same thing
done in a tiny bit of a different way so
don't be too intimidated but do be
annoyed I don't know what I'm always
annoyed by it I'm annoyed that there's
five different ways to get to the same
properties why just why why would you do
that
anyway doesn't really matter that much
just a little pet peeve of mine all
right
I think that'll cover it and I don't
know what I'm gonna cover in part three
but there's got to be something relevant
I can't think of anything this will be
kind of the end of getting set up
hopefully you can get set up with your
C++ project for these two videos and
don't forget to Like and subscribe hit
the bell button to be notified this
channel is not all about how to's it's
also kind of a comedy code channel so I
do these little videos kind of ranting
about things sometimes and going over
coding memes so if you're interested in
in humor
and coding humor and that subscribe for
that reason to yet another demographic
demographic that's not the right word
for another genre I don't know all right
well I'm out you guys keep coding do
some cool stuff and I'll see you in the
next one
peace out